who is Kevin Bacon who Kevin Bacon who
is who is kept hey this is Kevin Bacon
and today I am going to be doing the
Wired auto-complete interview yikes
[Music]
we really want to see what the internet
is asking why Kevin Bacon why is Kevin
Bacon famous Kevin Bacon is probably
famous because Kevin Bacon has worked so
hard his whole life at becoming famous
but other than that I can't come up with
a good reason why Kevin Bacon Avengers
why am i mentioning guardians of the
galaxy I don't really know but I could
tell you that someone said to me have
you seen guardians the galaxy yet and I
said no I haven't but I'm really looking
forward to it I said I think you should
see it and I they didn't tell me other
thing anything other than that and so I
was a little freaked out and I went to
the theater and I was all alone which I
do a lot when I go to the movies I go in
the afternoon I call it playing hooky
sitting there with my popcorn and all of
a sudden there they are talking about me
kind of blew my mind
why is Kevin Bacon not in tremors 2 I
did tremors 1 it was unfortunately a
movie that I loved and a lot of fun to
make and I thought it was a really cool
movie but nobody went to see it it was a
big hit on video and this is back in the
days of Blockbuster and VHS something
you kids won't remember but nobody had
seen it in the theater and back then I
didn't want to do movies that were going
straight to video that didn't seem like
fun so when they came to me for tremors
2 I said I think I'm gonna stick to
doing movies for the big screen for now
ok are you ready is Kevin Bacon he's
Kevin Bacon a good dancer I think I'm
okay but there's a lot of better dancers
than me but I'm okay it's Kevin Bacon an
Avenger not as far as I know Kevin Bacon
is not an Avenger
I mean I'm open to it it's Kevin Bacon a
UK citizen no I'm not I have an American
passport I do spend a lot of time in the
UK and I
to work there and the last movie that I
made you should have left we shot in the
UK and have a lot of fondness for that
country but I am NOT I'm an American
it's Kevin Bacon Canadian I just said
I'm American
no I'm not Canadian therefore I'm not
Canadian bacon
are you ready was Kevin Bacon was Kevin
Bacon in Top Gun not as far as I can
remember was Kevin Bacon on friends no I
was never on friends I did do one
episode of Will & Grace so maybe that
was your digital confusion was Kevin
Bacon the first choice in Footloose I
think I was but maybe not I probably
wasn't the first choice of the studio
but I think I was the first choice of
the director in the producer
let's move onto the next one can Kevin
Bacon can Kevin Bacon speak German no
Kevin Bacon nein Kevin Bacon cannot
speak German but Kevin Bacon worked
really hard on the German for x-men
first class and I didn't know exactly
what I was saying but as quickly as I
had learned it it went right out of my
head can Kevin Bacon do gymnastics no
Kevin Bacon cannot do gymnastics I
trained really hard for Footloose and
luckily had some extremely talented
gymnastic doubles to do the flips and
the end and the bar work for me and I
learned a couple of things but but no I
you know starting in gymnastics at 24
was really not a good idea can Kevin
Bacon still dance well it depends on
what you mean by dance yeah I mean I
like to dance I dance around the kitchen
do some you know Quarantine dancing
around the kitchen with my with my wife
sometimes if a song comes on that gets
us rockin but you know I'm definitely
not a trained dancer and never was on to
the next one
whoo Kevin Bacon who is Kevin Bacon
married to Kevin Bacon is married to the
great and power
for kyra sedgwick who does Kevin Bacon
look like the rest of his brothers and
sisters of which there are five I'm the
youngest of six I look a little bit like
my dad and a little bit like my mom and
a whole lot like my kids who is Kevin
Bacon related to Karen Bacon Elinor
bacon Hilda bacon Michael bacon Keira
bacon fun fact I have a sister named
Kira as well as a wife named Kira next
slide does Kevin Bacon does Kevin Bacon
have children yes I do I have two
children I have a 30 year old son and a
28 year old daughter does Kevin Bacon
have siblings
yes I am the youngest of six I have four
sisters and one brother is Kevin Bacon
drink alcohol Kevin Bacon has been known
to have the occasional adult beverage
yes my favorite drink is tequila a
silver tequila
or maybe a nun be a ho or maybe a
repertory
kind of sketchy or oaky I don't really
like two things too sweet but I like
just silver and lime and a couple pieces
of ice and I've already for a you know
an interesting evening does Kevin Bacon
do his own stunts what I do is I act
sometimes when I'm acting I will run or
fall or fight or jump or drive a car but
I don't like to call them stunts because
that's why we have stuntmen got nothing
to prove when it comes to what I'm
willing to do or not willing to do on a
set I'd like to stay as safe as possible
because I think I have a responsibility
to the rest of the people that are
employed on this project and the rest of
the cast members and and the people that
have hired me and are putting the money
up for the movie if I think there's
something of a physical nature that
looks like it's it's challenging and
cool and I can you know get away with it
not getting hurt and yeah I'll do it
this Kevin Bacon playing a band
yes I played a band I've been in a band
for about 25 years with my older brother
Michael the band is called the bacon
brothers and we are about to release our
ninth album does Kevin Bacon rap no I
don't rap I mean unless you're talking
about around Christmas time you know
I've been known to rap is Kevin Bacon to
have tattoos Kevin Bacon has one tattoo
on my arm on my shoulder when my
daughter was turning 18 I said hey how
about if we all got a family tattoo when
you turn 18 thinking that nobody was
going to go for it and both of my kids
to my shock said okay so I asked the
waitress for a cocktail napkin and a pen
and designed this tattoo that had the
the four of our initials in it and we
all went and got a family tattoo in
different different parts of our bodies
just Kevin Bacon sing I do sing well I
tried to sing I'm not the world's
greatest singer but I am a songwriter so
when I when I write my songs I somebody
has to sing oh yeah sure
come on let's tell the truth who hasn't
I want to meet somebody that's never
googled themselves that person doesn't
have Google
you